hoy vamos a hablar de variación
molecular en las células quizá ya estén
familiarizados con la idea de que
existen variaciones en las composiciones
o estructuras genéticas de una población
pero incluso dentro de un mismo
organismo existen variaciones en los
tipos de moléculas que puede producir el
organismo y cuando producirlas por
ejemplo sabemos que todos los organismos
vivos tenemos adn vamos a hacer un
dibujo de adn y también sabemos que hay
genes en el adn que se de codifican
eventualmente al pasar de arn mensajero
a rn para luego pasar a los ribosomas y
finalmente ser traducidos como proteínas
estas proteínas son una forma importante
de expresar lo que está codificado en el
adn resulta que el adn no solo codifica
varias proteínas sino que codifica
varios tipos de la misma proteína de las
cuales en ciertas circunstancias puede
codificar más de un mismo tipo y en
otras circunstancias puede producir más
de otro tipo de proteína dependiendo de
los factores ambientales esos factores
ambientales pueden influenciar cuál será
la parte
adn que será transcrita en arn m y que
después se traduce en proteínas en
momentos diferentes existen varios
ejemplos interesantes sobre esto resulta
que la hemoglobina que ustedes
recordarán como la proteína compleja que
se enlaza o se une al oxígeno que se
encuentra en las células rojas de la
sangre el tipo de hemoglobina
predominante cambia de cuando nos
encontramos en el vientre materno a
cuando nacemos y nos volvemos seres
independientes esta es la imagen de una
molécula de hemoglobina aquí vemos los
cuatro grupos en aquí vemos los cuatro
grupos gen que se enlazan al oxígeno
cuando somos fetos el tipo de
hemoglobina que predomina es la
hemoglobina efe y después de que nacemos
se deja de producir la hemoglobina efe y
comenzamos a producir hemoglobina y
quizás se pregunten por qué existe esta
variación en el tipo de hemoglobina la
respuesta es que nos encontramos en dos
ambientes diferentes cuando un feto se
encuentra en el vientre materno no está
respirando directamente ya que obtiene
el oxígeno de la sangre materna la
sangre de la madre no está mezclada con
la sangre del bebé
existe una capa límite que separa la
sangre de la madre de la sangre del bebé
y en esta capa se lleva a cabo el
intercambio de gases en donde el oxígeno
pasa a través de esta capa y también
pasa el dióxido de carbono en sentido
contrario en este ambiente en donde las
células rojas del bebé tienen que
enlazarse al oxígeno es un ambiente en
donde hay poco oxígeno en comparación
con el ambiente que hay en nuestros
pulmones ya que se mezcla la sangre
oxigenada con la sangre no oxigenada en
el mismo lugar no tiene un acceso
directo a los pulmones por ejemplo en
este ambiente con poco oxígeno es donde
las moléculas de hemoglobina tienen que
ser muy buenas para enlazar al oxígeno
podemos ver esto en este diagrama en
donde en el eje horizontal está la
presión parcial del oxígeno y en el eje
vertical es del porcentaje de saturación
de oxígeno que pueden tener estas
moléculas de hemoglobina podemos ver que
la hemoglobina fetal que es la curva
azul se satura al 50% con una presión
parcial menor de oxígeno comparada con
la hemoglobina de un adulto una forma de
pensar en esto es que la hemoglobina
fetal es más pegajosa y por eso se
enlaza mejor con el oxígeno en la sangre
esto
tiene sentido por el ambiente en el que
se encuentra el feto pero una vez que el
bebé nace pues ya no necesita más de esa
hemoglobina pegajosa pues este tipo de
hemoglobina tiene sus desventajas una de
ellas es que dificulta la transferencia
del oxígeno a los diversos tejidos del
cuerpo es por eso que ocurre la
transición de hemoglobina efe a
hemoglobina y no es solamente en la
hemoglobina en donde vemos esta
variación molecular las plantas y otros
organismos que realizan fotosíntesis
contienen varios tipos de clorofila
recordemos que la clorofila es una
molécula muy importante para capturar
energía de la luz la que después es
usada por seres como las plantas para
sintetizar carbohidratos aquí vemos dos
tipos diferentes de moléculas de
clorofila ambas se pueden encontrar en
plantas y en la gráfica se muestra que
tanto absorben la luz dependiendo de su
longitud de onda
vemos que la clorofila es muy buena para
absorber luz en longitudes de ondas
cercanas al azul o al ultravioleta
mientras que la clorofila ve es muy
buena para absorber la luz verde azul
más adelante vemos que hay otro pico en
donde la clorofila ve es bueno
para absorber la luz roja anaranjada
mientras que la clorofila
es buena para absorber la luz roja e
infrarroja esto se debe a que la planta
recibe diferentes longitudes de onda de
luz dependiendo de la hora del día y de
la época del año por lo que esto permite
que la planta captura más energía para
usar en la fotosíntesis estos son sólo
dos ejemplos de la variación molecular
en la membrana celular hay varios tipos
de fosfolípidos que forman la bicapa de
los fosfolípidos estos tipos tienen
diferentes niveles de fluidez a
diferentes temperaturas hay estudios en
animales que muestran cómo cambian las
variaciones dependiendo de las
condiciones por ejemplo los animales de
sangre fría tienen más de los
fosfolípidos más fluidos cuando hace
mucho frío para que las membranas no se
vuelvan demasiado rígidas hasta aquí
dejamos esta introducción a la variación
molecular donde apreciamos la idea de
que existe todo tipo de variación
molecular dentro de las células de los
organismos lo que permite a los
organismos a adaptarse mejor a sus
ambientes oa las diferentes etapas de su
desarrollo nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo